thanksgiving travel is up across the
board this year uh most people are
hitting the road according to aaa more
than 48 million are expected to travel
by car this week errol barnett is in
washington d.c checking on the holiday
traffic earl i hope you're not driving a
car right now good morning
no we are stable nate good morning to
you you can see behind me traffic here
in the nation's capital is already
picking up and it's a similar scene
across the country but consider it's
dramatically different than just one
year ago people weren't comfortable
heading out into crowds and vaccines
weren't even available it's it's totally
the opposite now and in fact pandemic
travel records are within reach over the
next few days
by driving we can just control our
travel a little more
joni odom and her two kids are gearing
up for a thanksgiving drive from laurel
maryland to long island new york we try
to leave it off hours and try not to
travel during those really
high traffic times because it's very
easy for that trip to become eight hours
instead of four odom stayed home last
year due to covid but with almost 60
percent of americans fully vaccinated
her confidence to keep a family
tradition is back it really just gives a
little more flexibility and some ease
with spending time with one another
soaring gas prices and inflation have
tinged the joys of hitting the road
again to help bring costs down president
biden announced a plan to release 50
million barrels of crude oil from the
country's strategic petroleum reserve
and as part of a coordinated effort five
other world powers announced they would
do the same our combined actions will
not solve the problem of high gas prices
overnight
it will make a difference congestion is
already building on roads
and at airports after summer
cancellations and delays thank you very
much welcome thank you airlines so far
are braving the pandemic holiday demand
the allen family is flying to birmingham
alabama seeing my mom of course
my brothers are there and so just being
able to spend that time with family to
catch up and to eat you know some good
things give them home yes yes yes eat
some good food
all the talk of food now if you are
heading out the top tips from aaa is to
get out as early as you can if you're
driving today try to hit the road before
12 noon if not wait until after 9 pm if
you're heading out on thanksgiving get
out before 11 and triple a suggests that
on sunday when everyone's heading back
try to hit the road before midday
michelle
well errol thank you